joining me today is an author a speaker
and the president of the Reagan legacy
foundation Michael Reagan welcome to the
report
hey good to be with you thanks for
having me I am glad to have you here you
come from a famous family is that fair
to say they tell me you know what I tell
people it's lobule they say famous
family but they don't understand how
absolutely famous it is
there's only healthy there's only two
people ever born and/or raised in a
family that the mother would go on to
become an academy award-winning actress
and the father would go on to become
president of the United States and
that's my sister Maureen passed away in
2001 and myself no one else has lived
that life and so that makes it more
understandable to me why people always
say so tell me about your family
yeah you know no matter what I've done
in life would tell me like your family
well it's not really uh I don't even
know if bizarre is the word but it
seemingly is a bizarre level of Fame
because there's a political element and
a Hollywood element and you combine
those two things and especially the way
these days where politics and how they
would have become the same thing it's
it's a unique place it is a unique place
I like to tell people about my mom Jane
Wyman down you know I say you know but
my mother has two stars in the Hollywood
Walk of Fame my dad only has one and my
mother also has her handprints and
footprints at Grauman's Chinese dad does
not so in Hollywood she won the game
politics he did yeah all right so let's
let's do a little we're gonna spend the
first half doing a little barrio and
talking about your dad and your mom and
the family and all that so just tell me
a little bit about just growing up you
grow yeah well you don't it growing up
it's itching it because people think hey
you're so lucky
I used to get that school you're so
lucky your parents are rich or famous
and you go yeah but I'm boarding at
school at six years old and that's what
a lot of people don't understand that
era of Hollywood children that's why we
all grew up mad at our parents because
we're boarding at school six years old
them at Chadwick school ranch at Palos
Verdes my sister's four years older than
me she's there also and people are
saying how lucky you are is your crying
yourself to sleep every night and so we
did we
grew up angry because we're very jealous
of the parents or the children who got
dropped off by their moms and dads every
single day at school and got picked up
and we didn't get picked up yeah and so
we grew up a little a little angst if
you will some of us wrote books about
those those days and that era
well what were your folks doing at that
well my mom my mom was an actress she
just won Academy Award in 1948 best
actress back in 48 my dad was you know
doing Hollywood he was president of
Screen Actors Guild dealing with all
those issues they got divorce and in
1948 so I was living with my mom at that
time in Beverly Hills hey I say to my
mom mom I want to be in your business
and she would say now no it's it you
don't want to be in this business really
tough you know it's a tough grind you
never know if you're gonna make it and
I'm thinking to myself I'm living in a
mansion in Beverly Hills
we got a maid we got a cook we've got a
Cadillac two stories I said I kind of
like this industry maybe you just don't
want the competition from a child and
and so that's that's what I grew up but
you know something it was really it was
really a great life at so many levels
because my parents never forgot where
they were from my mom was from st. Joe
Missouri my dad from Camco Illinois and
they brought those values with them when
they came to California so Maureen and I
even though not liking boarding at
school and being angry at times and
missing our parents terribly really got
grounded well with both my mom and my
dad because my dad even divorced from my
mother never forgot he had another
family even after he married Nancy so
when did your dad get involved in
politics when was that [ __ ] well he was
involved when he became president of
Screen Actors Guild so he's very to God
with that yeah it was 4years that gets
around 119 1950 yeah late 40s the 50s
and what have you
yeah well a lot of people don't know he
got involved more and more in politics
because the things kept on happening to
him you know he
was the king of the bees my mom was the
king of the A's if you will at the time
so his career wasn't going really well
it wasn't magic if you will he had to go
to Las Vegas to do a stand-up act and a
hotel in Vegas to make money they have
to have the family be able to eat
there's no video of that could there
possibly well there probably is video
somewhere on that but but again you know
back then they parents didn't share with
their children the tough times now
parents tell everything to their
children though which is crazy that's a
whole other show but if it really is but
you know we never knew until later on
the tough things dad was going through
ended up getting a show General Electric
Theater if you will out of that he's
doing GE theater going around the
country and speaking to General Electric
plants Bobby Kennedy picks up the phone
calls the president of General Electric
and says we have a problem the president
G is why is the Attorney General calling
me and the problem is since Ronald
Reagan's going around the country
speaking not well of his brother John
Kennedy at these plants about government
and Bobby Kennedy says to it basically
you know your your government contracts
are coming up for renewal and if you can
find a way to get rid of that guy you
could probably get your government
contracts renewed within 72 hours my
father a Democrat at the time yeah
General Electric Theater is canceled
Ronald Reagan doesn't have a job so what
does he do changes to a Republican yeah
so that was the moment that was the
moment changes to a Republican and and
then he has time to sit down because
he's not giving the speeches anymore and
he combines all the speeches he's been
giving and he ends up with a brand new
speech you might have heard of it a time
for choosing and gives it for Barry
Goldwater in 1964 and the rest is
history
Bobby Kennedy's does not make that phone
call my dad's not doing anything for
Goldwater
because he's too busy hosting one of the
top 10 television shows on Sunday night
on TV it's
incredible story because in an odd way
he was almost forced into the real part
of his political career you know he
never he never thought he was gonna run
for governor or president is tates
whatever he needed a job yeah
and he was forced out of the job he had
a job and when a very angry by Bobby
Kennedy yeah and it forced him to go to
the other other side if you will and
really as I said the rest of this
because your folks talked Wow oh no I I
called my mom one time after my dad gave
one of those great speeches he gave I
said Monty just your dad's speech last
night
she says no I heard it in 1938 didn't
like it they don't think much of it now
yeah but it just see enough you know
that I found after she passed going
through were things she'd written
letters to my dad she sent money to his
campaigns for governor for president
United States return letters from my
father to my mom never knew because she
never really talked politics at all
during her years in television she
stayed completely away from it and she
never say anything about my dad when he
was president until the day we buried
him and then she said some very nice
kind things what year did your folks get
divorced 1948 they were married in 1940
divorced in 1948 men on a set of a movie
so all right so let's flash forward a
little bit to now your dad now it's you
know late 70s and now he's sort of a guy
what was different you know we had my
dad got anything in that 20 year oh yeah
you never you never ready for a man or
anybody in your home to become president
united states of america because Secret
Service comes into your house I went all
over the country in 1980 well 76 and 80
I think the last month of 1980 66
airplane rides 19 states my sister
Maureen was doing this very same thing
and you know he gets elected in three
days later I've got Secret Service in my
life and our son gets Secret Service at
that time he's like two
they end up going to school with him it
really changes your life completely
anonymity you don't have you can't
really go anywhere you got to tell
somebody you're going there and have the
Secret Service follow you wherever you
go it's not the easiest life in the
world if you can imagine a
three-year-old going to preschool with
Secret Service protection or my wife
Colleen when she gave birth to our
daughter Ashley we found out her
codename which was you know raindrop
before we knew she was a girl I mean the
first thing my wife heard as Ashley was
being born was we have an arrival
raindrop has arrived we have an arrival
raindrop has arrived and my wife looked
at me she said is there anything private
about my life anymore I said no not
really
boy that's where children stop with two
because that's never gonna happen again
yeah but we found out her codename
before we find out she was a girl how
did that wear on you guys wants that
level of fame in that level of intrusive
if you can if you could keep a marriage
together for eight years of Secret
Service protection your marriage will
last forever and we just had our 43rd
wedding anniversary we celebrated our
45th year of our first date last
December 7th it's very very tough
because Secret Service has given the
blood relatives downward not given to
spouses so clean didn't have Secret
Service we did and and it's very
different you know cleaning out these
visions of driving on the freeway family
accident all thrown from the car
Secret Service pick up Cameron Ashley
and maid put us in an ambulance take us
to the hospital
throw cleaning a cell phone and say call
someone I think that's the vision you're
at right because she thought she doesn't
have that protection so not easy at all
being married you know in that situation
but we've month care I got a great wife
from Nebraska very strong she looks at
me as a stocker corn she planted me and
she just keeps on taking care of me all
these years what was your relationship
with your dad like as he was first
running for president I wrote a book
called less and my father taught me
about all those years going out to the
ranch when I was a child
learned about America heard every every
song of every military operation known
to mankind he was a true patriot and
that's why I learned about the tax laws
in America that's where I learned about
American and the greatness of America
and and riding out to the ranch with him
and riding horses and shooting ground
squirrels and going swimming and cutting
firewood
I bought him his first chainsaw when you
become president that all goes away
because now he's got John Barletta from
Secret Service who just passed away a
few months ago you know riding with my
dad and and it just completely changed
you don't have those close moments that
in fact you had previous so my greatest
years my dad was prior to the election
and the great years
after he came out of office we got to
spend time together and and when he had
you know that terrible terrible disease
that he had so many people had
Alzheimer's
we probably build the best relationship
for a ship of our lives because in 1992
I made a decision and the decision was
the next time I see my dad I'm gonna hug
him and tell him I love him and I did
that in 1992 and he hugged me back and
said I love you too and that point on
every time we would see each other we
would hug each other and say I love you
when he got Alzheimer's and he got to a
point he could no longer say my name
he remembered I was the young man who
hugged him alone hugged him goodbye and
so when he saw me he would open up his
arms not able to say my name and I fall
into his arms and give me that little
hug and I'd hug him and one day we're up
visiting Nancy at the house because you
no longer visit with dad and we'd be
there and I got up to leave and got to
the car and Colleen says to me you
forgot some things whatever get look at
the door I look back at the front door
of the house
and dad had remembered that I had
forgotten to hug him goodbye
Wow and he had gotten up a Nancy had
helped him a little baby steps all the
way the front door he was standing in
the front door like this I had forgotten
to hug him goodbye
I said oh my god and Ranbir Oh tear up
thinking about and hugged him and he
hugged me back and he turned to the baby
steps back into the house but just one
of those wonderful moments I just had
with my dad after he was out of the
White House yeah was there was it tough
for you the way people would talk about
your dad and Nancy obviously that she
wasn't your she wasn't your mom that
that relationship was the one that
everyone focused on and it was a
relationship that was in the house
saying that the relationship you saw is
what Patti Ron and I a marine lived it
was about them you couldn't get him
apart with a crowbar and and that's just
the way it was I write it right in my
book about the fact that dad when my mom
divorced him he will tell you or he
would have told you it was the worst day
of his life he's I'm never gonna let
this happened to me again Nancy's dad
walked out on her and her mother the day
she was born
walked out gone goodbye didn't want a
kid I'm out of here
she swore when she grew up I'm never
gonna have another man walk out on me
these two meet at Chasen's for dinner
get together and these two people you
could not get him apart with a crowbar
and so even as kids had a fight her way
into the system to get our time you know
with dad especially and and that's just
the way it was I think it was depicted
pretty well in the funeral for Nancy and
dad and so on that's just the way it was
with Nancy she was kind of the
gatekeeper if you will getting to our
Father and in the place you could really
spend time with him is getting to the
ranch you could be with him at the ranch
you got a lot of great time what is he
happiest there I mean when he could get
away from the political craziness love
the ranch
yeah you know young America's Foundation
bought it a few years ago I do a lot of
things with them
they bring high school kids up there and
college kids up there and I speak to
them
he really referred to it as his
Cathedral and it really was his
Cathedral this is where he could go up
and really relax that cutting wood he
did all that stuff when you go and see
the ranch he's the one that really built
the fences and did all of it so when you
see all those pictures of him it's real
as opposed to now where everything is so
staged every time a politician shows up
anywhere in a hat with this or holding
the pitchfork or just any anything oh no
it's so oh yeah it was a lot of first I
mean that you're very true about him you
know he was the first president to show
up on d-day at Normandy yeah he was the
first president to salute getting on off
Air Force One a marine one you know he
put a lot of firsts that are out there
that now have been followed by others
yeah talk to me a little bit about those
first couple years of the presidency and
it was definitely not all easy no it
wasn't easy and but you know I the
interesting enough when I was
campaigning for him in 1980 called him
on the phone from Iowa and he and he's
talking to me and I said dad you know
you're gonna get beat by George HW Bush
here in Iowa do I just got the phone the
campaign staff and they said we're doing
finance well they're lying to you I said
I've been all over this state now for
the last three weeks doing coffees FM's
20 doughnuts by 8 o'clock in the morning
eighty-seven cups of coffee that's the
vivid and doing all these things I said
I'm telling you you're gonna get because
you're not here this is your state
you're the favorite son of the state WH
I was doing an event Saturday you're not
even gonna be at it because your staff
doesn't think you need to be there
they're running you is if you're better
than the people in Iowa and he's going
to beat you to give me a typical
father's thank you Michael appreciate
the call thank you for helping out in
Iowa but my staff says I'm good
who wins Iowa HW Bush a couple weeks
later in New Hampshire I get a call it
6:30 in the morning at the house he says
I have a press release for you I said
why are you calling me is that press
release I need your approval on or
disapproval it's up to you
so why you calling me said let me read
you the press release and you tell me
whether I should give it to the media
or not it's your call it's the press
release firing Roger stone Paul manna
Ford John Sears and Charlie black he
calls me there now and and I said the
news that's right and I said done do it
he says fine you'll be hearing about
your 7:00 o'clock news hour I'm gonna
get off the phone with you and give it
to the media and then I thought to
myself what happens if he loses the day
they're gonna blame me I said my dad
said you're gonna win today's just yeah
we're gonna win - I said go ahead go
ahead and do it he says give my love to
Colleen and and the camera at the time
we didn't have Ashley that's a goodbye
dad so you know these are things he
would do as president because he knew
the dynamics to allow me the opportunity
to fire these guys was amazing so when
you hear these guys names now Matt
afford and stone and some of the others
that they're so in the news lately but
what does that ring to you I've known
they've been evil for years
I mean it's amazed me the Republican
Party keeps on going back to the same
well over all these years I mean
Charlie's okay but I mean stone and and
and in man afford have always been like
this I mean it's just the truth
and I I tweeted I remember during the
campaign with Trump I said you know
Ronald Reagan with Manta Fortin stone
never won without them never lost and I
said I suggest you know to Trump you
want to see the same dynamic I would get
rid of both of them and it really turned
it around because he was doing very
badly when they got rid of them he never
lost again what year was the
assassination attempt that was gay 19 in
March 30 1981 81 that is actually I
think that is my first real memory of
anything you know I vision I was 5 years
old at the time 95 about four and a half
or so and I remember my folks watching
that and I remember seeing on the news
you know they had like an image of
Carter like not mature a character of
his body and I vividly remember that at
that age what was that like
you know I was in my office Secret
Service I was in business me in my
office and Secret Service agent came in
said there's been an assassination
attempt
back in Washington everything's okay it
was my cloody and my agent charged my
detail that day and he's but
everything's okay he closed the door and
I went but people looked at me like that
was cold yeah that was cold so I picked
up the phone called the White House
asked for Nancy Nancy wasn't at the
White House I walked I said Mike my
dad's been shot
here's know he's fine I said no Nancy's
not at the White House there's only one
reason she wouldn't be at the White
House and the car was on the way to the
White House if she's not there she's
someplace else and I would say that
would be the hospital and Mike said no
they say he's fun they said check it
five minutes later Mike says you're
right he was shot
so now we go home and of course the
press just surrounded our house we're
being held captive basically in the home
and they finally sent a plane out from
Washington to pick us up but we were
asked to stay home they didn't want us
to rush to Washington for fear the
markets would crash people would think
it was worse than it really was but it
really was worse than people thought it
was because he was very close to death
if Jerry Parr was the agent charge that
day if Jerry if dead and not coughed up
oxygenated blood they would have gone to
the White House he would have bled to
death internally but he did right at the
right time and they went to the hospital
and I tell the story when they get the
hospital they cut the suit off of my dad
you now see at the library and I
remember the next day we were able to
see that we finally got in very late at
night saw dad 10 o'clock the next
morning and the humor that he shared
with the country it's the same humor II
always shared with the family he always
had a joke
he always had a sense of humor Elsa was
great about dad unless you were Russian
his life was great yeah we'll get to
that and and I shall I walk in I walk in
10 o'clock with my family my dad looks
me sees you know you know yesterday I
was shot I
dad the world knows you were shot
yesterday he says well if you're ever
gonna get shot don't be wearing a new
suit I said what he says when I was shot
yesterday I had a brand new suit I just
picked it up the day before he says I
can't I walked in the hospital and they
put me on this gurney and they cut that
suit off of my body and the last time I
saw I was in shreds in the corner of the
hospital room that's why I tell you
Michael
everything gets shot don't be worried in
his suit I said fine I won't wear a new
suit I'll talk to Lane to put something
else on me and he says that young man
who shot me I said yeah John Hinckley
yes it was John Hinckley I said what he
says I understand his parents from the
oil business yes I understand they live
in Denver yeah do you think they have
any money not heirs dear he was on the
table close to death six hours before
I'm in the room put that in perspective
and I said well if they live in Denver
they're in the oil business Dan I'm sure
they have money he says do you think
they'd ever buy me a new suit that's
what he says to me and I just looked at
him I said ask I don't know but that's
what he says to me six hours after off
the table how did that experience change
him you know how a change was and people
have written books they really need to
call family members so many people who
write books don't they think they know
everything but you know family members
have the inside baseball stories you
don't want to go there
and so it's been upsetting some of the
things been said how it changed him was
that he believed he was truly saved for
a reason
and he became closer really to God if
you will and that and that's where he
was and and and a lot of people just
misunderstood that they you know wasn't
the same guy he wasn't the same guy but
he did put a gym in on the second floor
of the White House put two and a half
inches on his chest you know and got
stronger because of the wood the bullet
wound and what-have-you but he just
became more he came became closer to God
and felt that there was a reason he was
there and you know some he ended up
being right so did that then galvanized
a lot of things that he ended up doing
in the second term and everything that
happened with Russia had mr. Gorbachev
tear down this wall whatever yeah yeah
yeah
binky because if you look I mean you
understand my dad it's March 31st three
months later who shot Pope John Paul
yeah and he lives so what is the first
thing my father does I tell people just
want to go out and speak how many people
you speak to if you ask the question how
many can recite the Lord's Prayer how
many people would raise their hand how
many you know how many people don't live
the Lord's Prayer because my dad before
he went back to the White House forgave
John Hinckley for trying to kill him
Pope John Paul before he went back to
his papal duties forgave the young man
who tried to kill him
two months later three months later both
of them meet in Rome at the Vatican what
do they now have in common to really
talk about both believing they've been
saved for a higher purpose and the
higher purpose becomes what freedom to
Poland and the Berlin Wall ultimately
coming down so that he always had that
message of freedom in it I mean that
that idea of the individual and freedom
and you know so the line and we touched
on this earlier but the line of I didn't
leave the Democratic Party the
Democratic Party left me hmm that's
become very to me that's like that's it
because I was a big lefty most of my
life and even and just in the last five
years I've sort of woken up they become
I know that's probably funny to you and
if you know but look dad was sitting
here he'd say what - my sister Marie was
the first Republican in the family yeah
he's the one that really you know pushed
him and pushed him and pushed him to to
do all this so so when he said that was
was he really saying well that was was
the effect of what he was saying I get I
get what happened with GM was just that
that when they left me meaning that they
want government to solve everything and
that's just not what I want yeah and
that's not the way they used to be but
if you go back to take you back
historically yeah back then a a Liberal
Democrat was a conservative yeah
today of course would be a conservative
I mean the reality is John Kennedy today
would be a conservative and the fact is
that today while Reagan may be a liberal
yeah I mean not where they are but I
realize no I go back and say you know as
governor he raised taxes signed abortion
pill and what-have-you and instead
things later on in his life but now with
all the social media and all the things
out there you know people remember what
you did you know at birth and they're
holding against you in the public
opinion in that court which is tough to
do so it's a it's a tough world out
there anymore and a loaf Ronald Reagan
who gave amnesty in 1986 which stand you
know there's people who wouldn't support
him today yeah what do you think he
would make of just generally the way
politics is now in terms of its decides
that seemingly won't talk to each other
were in the worry what week six of a
shutdown just the whole tenor of
everything yeah it's not something that
he would wrap his arms around you man
when he was elected we don't have any
statesmen anymore we used to have States
on both sides yeah yeah Hubert Humphrey
you let's go through the list of people
you disagreed with maybe politically but
they were great statesmen you know you
great debate at the end of the debate we
all had dinner together type thing you
know back in the day we have the largest
tax break in American history but how do
we get that Tip O'Neill was the head of
the house he was speaker house here's
the guy who disagree with my father on
everything known to mankind
yeah what was dad do fights in the White
House for dinner with his wife he goes
up there for dinner a couple of days
later when he's back in his office tells
his staff I'm going to carry the
legislation on the tax cut staff looks
at him said you're nuts
there's boll weevils they used to be
boll weevils before they get Blue Dog
Democrat how do I give you some period
big yes boys there's enough Bo wheels on
the on the House floor that little
pastor you put it on the floor what did
the president promise you
What did he say was going to give you to
put it
the floor there's nothing nothing then
what did you talk about we never talked
about taxes on that long then what did
you talk about with the president
greatness of America the goodness of her
people and now the two of us working
together and make it better for all
Americans before I knew it
we're telling Irish stories we're having
a glass of wine today I'm telling I'm
gonna carry the legislation you can't do
that today
so do you think that was his greatest
skill beyond political maneuvering per
se although I guess that is political
maneuvering at its at its core yeah yeah
well he also said to him cut as an aside
he says and by the way I promised not to
campaign against any Democrats who
support it in the next election which
helped a lot yeah that's because he had
a lot going for him but he was the same
thing working with Gorbachev you know
same thing work with with all of them he
just you know well Reagan for best
friend as Jimmy Stewart said Ronald
Reagan for best friend he was that kind
of a guy easy to get along with but he
knew what he wanted and he knew the best
way to go about getting it and he and he
did it what was it like watching the
media go after your dad either either
justly or unjustly that could not have
been fun
well yeah it's something you know it
gets maddening
I remember Maury and I when he when he
was campaigning in New Hampshire he paid
for the microphone and Maury and I look
to each other when it's about time he
got mad dad never gets mad yeah he
finally got mad and we thought that was
that was a change of two excuse me in in
in New Hampshire but it's tough watching
people attack anybody in your family it
didn't bother dad nothing didn't bother
him and all that yeah Nancy would eat
bananas at night she wouldn't sleep she
toss and turn she called everybody known
to mankind to see how do we stop this
how do we stop it
but dad was just don plus play he didn't
let it bother him he wasn't thin-skinned
yeah I want it I mean some of that has
to be maybe some of the acting career
and he was he was at a level of Fame
that was so
surd that you'd lived through the
struggle years and oh yeah beyond the
tough years much where they came after
yeah I mean he had the tough years it
wasn't an easy life he but he never let
anything stop him from really moving the
ball forward and getting things done and
and I think that's important a lot of
people today you know if they get
stopped here you know they stop they
don't do anything else you know instead
of finding out you know what next what
door opened up now that I can go into
and and maybe make a career out of it if
you will and I think that's lessons that
can be taught to a lot of people today
that you know everything's to work in
progress
I'm a UPS guy the other day was at my
house delivering something and and it's
kind of a snide remark nice house as he
was leaving and I said yeah it took me
50 years to get here oh what's it board
here I took me 50 years to get this
house a lot of people don't know about
you know if you want something you got
to work for it
nobody's gonna hand it to you my mother
taught me that you know back when I was
10 years old I want a ten-speed bike all
my other friends were getting 10 Speaks
bikes given to him by their parents for
free I went down Hansard Cyclery Santa
Monica picked out a blue ten-speed
Schwinn bike went home said to my mom
mom you buy me this I'm gonna love you
forever
no kids ever done that with his parents
my mom said well how badly do you want
it I said mom want more than anything
good do you want it enough to get a job
I said what job I'm 10 years old she
deliver papers what so she opens up the
paper looking for ads ah you could sell
papers in Friday Good Shepherd Church
and Santa Monica where we go to church
on Sunday mornings it's available signed
here I signed a contract with my mother
when I was 10 years old she loaned me
the money to buy that bike and I would
pay her back on Sunday afternoon after
church was some of the profits I made
from selling by then 25 cents for a
Sunday paper that was this thick but I
when I met what I made I give it back to
her and I asked her I said why are you
doing
to me all my friends are getting bikes
given to them she says because I build
men not boys if I give you what you want
you'll be a 40 year old child but if I
teach you now did you have to work for
what you want in life you'll be a 40
year old man and that's what I built so
you deserve that house damn right all
right so let's just do a little bit more
about your dad and then I want to spend
the rest of the time talking about what
you're doing now in the foundation and
everything else so I think it's pretty
fair to say that the that the fall of
the Soviet Union was was his greatest
accomplishment oh yeah I don't know what
other than bringing me into the family
other me coming in the family was there
anything when he left the presidency
that he really felt was undone or that
he had really no he had no regrets at
all I think you look at his last speech
that he gave really talked about the
things that had been accomplished he was
a great guy for using we non-ai
and he really understood it was a team
effort and very happy with what he was
able to accomplish and being able to
work with with others and and yeah I
said to Margaret Thatcher the day after
the funeral she came to me we're having
breakfast at Hotel and she said Oh
Michel about your dad just think of what
we could have accomplished it would have
been elected in 1976
I said Lady Thatcher if he'd been
elected in 76 the Berlin wall would
still be up the Cold War would still be
in place she said why do you say that I
said where were you in 76 where was John
Paul where was like valensa work was
vaclav havel where was Mikhail Gorbachev
they all need each other the fact the
matter is he'd been elected then he
would have been out of office even it
was a two-term president by the time
Mikhail Gorbachev came in the wall would
still be up for some reason faith you
name it all the right people were in the
right place at the right time and my dad
was that leader able to work with each
and every one of you Helmut Kohl you
name it
to bring everybody together Pope John
Paul that ultimately brought down that
Berlin wall all of you are on the same
page up until that point all of you were
on other pages and it's my dad's that
that one card he had on his desk no
telling what you had accomplished and
where you can go if you don't worry who
gets the credit dad didn't worry about
credit he worried about getting the job
done he wanted to bring that wall down
if you go back historically and look and
listen to my father's speeches he was
talking about that wall back when it was
put up back in what 1961 two o'clock in
the morning August 13th I believe he
talked about that wall from that point
forward in his life and so that was that
was the seminal thing for him and that
wall coming down changed the world so he
obviously was an incredible communicator
and the speeches and all that and
obviously we had a way of reaching
across the aisle were there any people
either that were US politicians or
international figures that he just
absolutely hated or felt that he could
not work with was there anyone no anyway
he didn't feel that way about anybody he
brought him on he really because there
were people that hated him I mean we're
motive but but you know he look at was
sitting behind us if you go to his
funeral look who was sitting behind us
at the at the church Mikhail Gorbachev
you know the the he made friends of
enemies he didn't make enemies of
friends and he diffused so many things
because of his humor being able to laugh
at himself last year the year before on
February 6 his birthday was celebrated
at the everywhere but the Reagan Library
does a big event u.s. Marines come up
and what have you guest speaker last
year sam donaldson that wouldn't happen
today yeah not gonna happen at all even
though they had this adversarial way
they have mutual respect and in all
things you have Sam Donaldson speaking
you know on behalf of my father at his
birthday last year at the library
he made friends of people who were
enemies and got things accomplished
whether it's Pope John Paul like the
Lance of Akko hobble doesn't matter who
it is Mikhail Gorbachev you know turned
turned him and Mikhail Gorbachev I
worked with Eureka College a few years
ago we're able to get Mikhail Gorbachev
go to Eureka College my dad's alma mater
and speak to the Reagan Society at
Eureka College about his relationship
with my dad wouldn't happened today and
and that's what's that's what's sad you
things see things deteriorate possibly
when they're it's such a great
high-level relationship in all areas
yeah so you obviously mentioned your dad
in later years and obviously Alzheimer's
is there's no words to truly describe in
the story he told was incredible do you
remember the moment that you knew
something was off because he was must
have been this otherworldly figure in a
way even to you do you remember seeing
him one day yeah he was he was gay he
was losing a step if you will and they
had an event celebrating his birthday at
the library or not at the library what
would become and they had a big event
and Lady Thatcher was a speaker and
there had to be a thousand people and
under this tent is great and my dad
introduced Lady Thatcher and to a great
round of applause and when the Palazzo
was over he reintroduced her the exact
same way he had just done and everybody
got it and everybody applauded again and
that was the moment where I think the
decision was probably made that there's
too many people in the room that saw it
that he had to say something and that's
when the letter comes out in 1999 for
the letter comes in November third I
think 1994 when the letter comes out
because too many people the room saw
that moment if you will but everybody
you know who had just give a standing
ovation to Lady Thatcher and my dad
stood up and gave another standing
ovation
to believe that you're a my dad and and
that that was the that was the moment
where we knew that it was going to
blossom from there to National Enquirer
and you didn't want National Enquirer
breaking the story you wanted the family
to breaking the story and Dad of course
with the letter he wrote to the nation
after the letter he didn't do any public
appearances did he hi I don't think he I
don't think he did any after that I
think the last one he gave was in that
year but prior to the prior to the
letter he might have given one if you
will but it wasn't it wasn't easy still
I mean it wasn't just the early onset if
you will of what he had I chaired the
John Douglas French Alzheimer's
foundation for four years I just left it
this this last year and you know we just
we're doing a whole program with UCLA
and SC and colleges we took University
of San Francisco where we took I think
we had ten eleven million dollars in the
bank and what we're doing is doing
matching funds with these universities
and creating chairs so we turn the
eleven into twenty two million that is
used strictly for research for
Alzheimer's there's the new program
CRISPR that looks very promising in the
future we're part of that so you know
people think maybe within five years
something of CRISPR does what everybody
thinks that might be able to do it'd be
great for for that for that issue
alright so that's a pretty good segue
and what you're doing now and your dad's
legacy you are the president of the
Reagan legacy foundation how do you keep
a legacy like this life this is this is
not an easy thing to to chew off you
know when my sister Maureen was dying of
melanoma back in 2001 I was with her in
her hospital room there's about three
months before she passed she was st.
John's in Santa Monica chased everybody
else out Newsday and we had that
brother-sister conversation and she
really worried about our dad's legacy
and she asked he said Michael he
ever gets to a point you can walk away
from radio would you I said why are you
asking she says our Father has a very
important legacy and I would hope that
you in fact would help carry it for
people remember who he was who he is who
he was and I promised her than I would
so 2009 I chose to leave 26 years in
radio yeah
walked away from radio which is pretty
tough because I'll said oh I got to make
a living too and and I take no money
from the foundation I said oh that's why
I needed to create a foundation and make
money media won't have fun with that one
right right right so I'm out speaking
Premier speaker's bureau picked me up I
without speaking a lot 30 40 50 speeches
a year and what having started as
foundation which originally was used to
it still does to provide scholarships to
men and women to serve aboard the USS
Ronald Reagan which now is in Tokyo
Japan keeping an eye on North Korea and
so we provide scholarships to the young
men and women who serve on the Reagan
but we do something different we also
provide scholarships to their family
members who are left back home nobody
else thinks about that they're serving
as much as the one on the ship and
they're trying to better their lives
education so we provide thousand dollar
scholarships goes on the ship $2000
scholarships to those left home we do it
every single year but somewhere between
25 and 50 thousand dollars a year we
whatever we can race we raised a million
it'll be a million whatever it might be
we do that and and then I was in Germany
a few years ago and I would sit the
Berlin Wall asked some young man what do
you know Berlin Wall
he said well the Americans played up to
keep the Communists out of their sector
is askew thing I said boy we did a great
job with our education system but there
is no mention to Ronald Reagan nothing
at the Brandenburg Gate nothing so I
build a relationship with Frau
Hildebrand her her and her husband who
created the the Maurer Museum which is
the checkpoint charlie Museum in Berlin
and we funded through the Reagan legacy
foundation a Ronald Reagan exhibit
overlooking checkpoint charlie there
at that Museum so you can learn about my
father who got chainsaw there all kinds
of stuff the speech for the Brandenburg
Gate is there and that's it well we need
to put something in the ground at the
Brandenburg Gate so I worked almost
three years working with the red red
government of Berlin and finally about
two years ago three years ago they
approved as putting a plaque in the
ground so the the Adelaide hotel which
is that from the Brandenburg Gate
there's we have a huge you know program
there heard our a thing of my dad
commemorating the speech of black my dad
commemorating the speech back in 1987
June 12 so I did that we're fun Mike
it's great then I'm playing golf with a
young man here in Los Angeles
years later 28 years old I said you know
I'm leaving tomorrow for Paris and then
I'm going out to going out to Normandy
on Saturday and Sunday I've been asked
to raise the American flag at the
American Cemetery 28 year old young man
says to me why is there an american
cemetery at normandy i went oh my god
did you think d-day is when your report
card came home so i did that
spent more time out there then and
realized there's no mention of ronald
reagan there at normandy especially at
that great speech and so we now
partnered with the airborne museum it's
Sainte mère église Saint Mary glaze
first time freed by America on d-day
that's where all the paratroopers are
going Saving Private Ryan that's where
they were headed that's where the
bridges were it is the the 82nd airborne
in the hundred and first there Waterloo
if you will or their Gettysburg and we
partner with them and we have now a
Ronald Reagan Center there too to have
conferences we produced a film about
that you can go on my website Reagan
legacy foundation.org watch the film on
that and so what else can we do and so
last year we put together a program with
the airborne museum to start doing what
we call a walkway to victory where you
can you can buy a brick go online walk
way to victory calm or Reagan
foundation.org and you can purchase a
brick $250 over 500 whatever you want
spend and we're putting the names of
those who served in the European theater
in the Second World War and if you don't
know somebody you can donate to the
foundation and we'll find that somebody
so you're actually building it over time
oh it's coming in so you it launched
last June last I think yeah just but we
put the first group in I think April or
May we have about 300 bricks now we have
another order in now to put more bricks
in a lot of it's weather you can't do it
because of weather is there at Normandy
but people go online and do that and
it's a great way to honor those who
fought in the Second World War in the
European theater and and really changed
the world and have we changed part of
what you guys are teaching about I mean
there's there's incredible stories that
would never happen now I mean about
about actors so after some have your dad
and athletes that actually put their
careers on hold you know to fight in
world war ii which now to an athlete or
an actor these days would sound it would
sound insane oh yeah
now my dad couldn't go there because he
was legally blind so he did over 300
films training films for those who
didn't go there but you have so many of
these actors who who signed up and win
or you have there was there was a TV
show on Netflix I think it was the five
that kids five came back during the
famous directors of the time who came
back but they were sent there and
they're the ones who took the film of
all those encampments that we saw of the
Jews that's how we found out about these
things that were going on so we'll have
special places put out for them actors
sports that the people who were involved
who went there and and gave up their
careers if you will to go there came
back and we got the careers going if you
will but it is it's such a great place
anybody who goes to Normandy needs to
stop at st. Mary Glee's people don't
know that the the gravesites did you see
at the American Cemetery all of them
were in that area of st. Mary Gleason
through there there were gosh thousand
15,000 grave sites
they were there and the wife of the
d-day mayor of st. Mary Glee's called
the mother of Normandy was the one who
took care of those grave sites all of
those years making contact with the
loved ones that were left home and when
they made the agreement the Americans
with the French to have the American
Cemetery
they gave the availability to the family
members home to have their loved ones
sent back home or sent to the American
Cemetery that's where there's 9600 the
American Cemetery and there are 15,000
sprint spreads throughout st. Mary
Glee's and and to go there and go the
airborne museum and and and see the
gliders and see how these these guys
came in and what we what was going on
that day at st. Mary glaze is absolutely
phenomenal and to be able to remember
them with these bricks and what happens
in the 250 bucks okay what happens is
the money I'll tell you what happens the
money we paid by the get the brick put
it in the ground the profits are
leftover which you're pretty good are
split between the airborne museum for
their museum yeah the upkeep and the
Reagan legacy foundation which does what
provide scholarships for men and women
aboard the USS Ronald Reagan that's what
we did because that was my father's a
lot of people don't know you go back and
you listen that speech it point the hawk
speech and think he was the first
president think about that
it was 40th anniversary he was the first
president thought you maybe I should
show up on d-day at st. Mary Glazer at
Normandy and give a speech and he and he
did and and that his idea yeah it was
his idea he you know my sister and I
used to laugh about dad that if he
didn't win the presidency United States
we taught him as a boy scout we thought
him running for the Presidency was like
going for your Eagle badge yeah I mean
that was my dad he was the Eagle Scout
going for his Eagle badge he never
forgot about those who who gave their
lives as I said 300 training films that
he did he was legally blind it couldn't
serve overseas one
in the army was in the he was in the
cavalry but to get the army at a past
and I examine so what does he do he went
out and he memorized the eye chart so we
went in to join the army they put him in
front of an eye chart cover your left
eye right I read line three he had it
memorized and so he de fpq EURion Reagan
and then when they offered him the rank
of Major
to stay in he said no the rank of Major
should be given only to someone who's
able to serve overseas not someone who
has to be able can only stay home so
please give that major as someone who
serves overseas I'll retire as a captain
and that's what he did and then he
retired as president right State so it
worked out pretty well yeah but that was
his heart it was never about him do you
feel it's well you and that's let me
tell you how tough that is to live up to
yeah I mean when you've got my iconic
parents well that's exactly what I was
gonna ask you that for you right now
it's like you have your mission which is
the next part of his mission in a way
and I've been up to the to the library
and Simeon it's incredible I was at the
first Democrat debate there two two and
a half years ago or so incredible
building and just wonderful what else
are you guys doing to keep these ideas
alive because that's really what will I
mean the library and the library does
you know what they do having two people
come up there the debates that they have
there they have guests up there on a
regular Gary Sinise is going to be up
there pretty soon and then I work with
the young America's Foundation and at
the Reagan Ranch Center in Santa Barbara
and the Reagan ranch where they bring
high school kids from all over the
country come in they bring in speakers
to speak there at the ranch center they
have lunches on Friday with speakers
they bring in college kids from all over
the country to be able to come in and go
up and walk in the footsteps of Ronald
Reagan and see the ranch I mean people
go up there and think they're gonna see
this great mansion his his his ranch
house would probably fit in your studio
I mean it just really
the ranch house you don't go in there
and see pictures of him with famous
people you go in there and see paintings
of horses
it's a ranch else that's what it is and
that's where he loved to be in and he
when you walk in the door of the ranch
house you see a a a big magazine from
Montgomery Ward and the reason he has
that there is first job he ever tried to
get was with Montgomery Ward in Iowa he
turned him down and that's how he got
into radio he turned him down for
Montgomery Ward job you'll never make a
kid goes over to WH o or w OC radio ends
up getting a job as a sportscaster w OC
and moves right look he'd never let
someone else my wife told me this and my
dad lived it and greatest thing that
Colleen ever told me don't let somebody
else's attitude determine your attitude
for the remainder of the day and and my
dad lived it and until I started to
learn to live that I was a train wreck
so the ideas the ideas that he believed
in the corners and the things you've
talked about here about about freedom
and that he he basically saved
capitalism and saved the West and all of
these things when you see these days
that there's this idea out there that
socialism is cool for young people are
you you hear this now I mean I see you
on Twitter you talk about this stuff
scary it is scary yes because our our
education system scary you know what you
think you think about the thinking about
state health REM born and raised in
people don't know there used to be
number one in education it's now 46th in
education I mean we're not educating our
kids we've become politically correct to
the education system I remember when I
went there is on a state which would
disallow me from ever running for
Supreme Court justice because we're on
social probation Arizona State
everybody's on social probation we
earned it the old-fashioned way but you
know well at school you know we're heard
from many different philosophers
different different beliefs
you heard them all and you know every
week you said that
really good I think I'll be that this
week and the next week here another but
you get you learn things you have that
breath the knowledge yeah and you did
today it's it's it's completely
different when you have schools who who
if you walk into some schools and you
have a a Reagan hat yeah you know they
get upset with you or it just so
polarized nobody's conversely nobody's
talking nobody's sitting down just let's
have a conversation
let's find things that we agree on it's
it's always your you go to dinner you're
afraid if there's somebody sitting next
to you afraid of saying anything for
fear these people on this side - that's
like may get upset with what you're
saying
and start yelling and screaming at you
and and and that said or you have
husbands wives saying now won't talk to
each other yeah and it never used to be
like that we used to be able to
communicate to sit down and and talk I
remember my dad saying to me one day his
dad told him he said you know when the
government starts paying and not to not
to work
why work his dad taught him that my dad
taught me that you know you try to teach
your kids that but now you try to teach
I mean everybody's got their like their
he their hand out it's really
interesting we support a little school
in the middle of a slum not the
Foundation's chol and I millet a slum in
in in in in Africa in Nairobi eight
hundred thousand the slum school in the
middle of it
there were uniforms they teach them
English they sing and they're smiling
and they tell you is you're going
through this slum they say if you see
somebody with their hand out please
don't put anything in it why because it
will keep them in the slum you want to
help the people to slum give them
educational material education is the
only way out of this slum and I'm
thinking to myself why do they get it
why do they understand it in a slum of
eight hundred thousand the middle of
Nairobi and if I talk about it here I'm
ridicule how can you do that how can you
say that yeah maybe we've become fat on
some of the success that's because your
dad you know and it's it really is sad
too
to look at I love traveling around the
world you travel around the world and
there's too many people here talking
what they think they know and they don't
know anything because they've never been
across their own border but they know
more than you do don't you find that
amazing yourself you go like really I
bid you go I've been there how do you
know that
yeah well all the time now you hear all
the all the progressives say well we
should just be more like Sweden Sweden
is a tiny socialist country that's
basically homogeneous until the last
couple years where no longer is and now
they have all sorts of problems and it's
like have you guys been there have you
seen let's go they'd never been there
but I know more about than you do you
just didn't see it when you were there
you know you didn't understand go okay
and that and so that you do you find
yourself unfortunately in a world today
where people are afraid of dialog they
don't want a dialogue and and find that
commonality like my father and Tip
O'Neill had to find a common ground to
give you a largest tax break in American
history I just had to find it whatever
it was
and there's the people elected Ronald
Reagan to talk about the Reagan
Democrats didn't necessarily agree with
him but they liked it they liked it and
because they liked him they supported
him and and and voted for him and you
know it's getting to a point you know
no I want to see us be likeable again
yeah all right so I don't want to end on
that note so let's end on if your dad
was here what would he be telling us in
this in this strange polarizing time
that we're talking about right now grow
up just grow up I mean really just
you're like he said there they go again
grow up and and find a way to work
together yeah that's that's what he's
safe he's very short very sweet
grow up you do a pretty good impression
of your dad by the way I only heard it
for a second there but you know we had
lunch one sitting it out I did on my
radio show one time too I did an
interview with my dad doing both sides
and the office called me and they said
had to get your dad on the air I said
what are you talking about yesterday
what are you talking about ABC NBC all
these people and there's a blackout on
your dad because of Alzheimer's
to get him on the air also I realized oh
my god
Wow I said well I called and he answered
the phone well he's not supposed to
answer the phone I said well somebody
should tell him and they said when the
answers must answer the phone I so
that's not my problem I call he picked
up the phone and said well you can't
have him on your show anymore and I said
well why don't let me ask my dad I said
dad do you want to be in my show again
and went well yes I do and also the
office goes oh my god I see if I do pull
ABC NBC and CBS and my dad's office I'm
doing pretty good
I'm gonna tell the people to go to
Reagan legacy foundation org but would
you prefer to do that as your dad uh
well yes if you could go to Reagan
legacy foundation org or walk going to
victory calm and really help help
remember those who truly did save the
world back in the back in the day in in
France and this is the way you can do it
as I said if you don't know someone who
served then you can donate to the
foundation and we have plenty of people
and names that will put a name on a
brick and and put it out there and what
we do is we'll send you a video we have
a 50 minute video that we did heroes in
world war two that we gives us people
who who purchase a brick and you'll get
a photo of the of the brick in the
ground there at st. Mary glazed Normandy
France and when you visit normally go to
Sainte mère église and look at the look
at the walkway to freedom walk we
deliver the walkway and and see the name
of the person that you bought if you put
a name on a brick well it's been a
pleasure chatting with ya and I sense
your dad's legacy is in good hands and I
will tell them where to go but I'm not
gonna do the impression you guys go to
Reagan legacy foundation org